do something
it's quite unmistakable that battlefront
has been developed at dice the Stockholm
studio made famous for its award-winning
battlefield series and while the
developer has made sincere efforts to
make battlefront are beautiful and
lovingly crafted homage to the Star Wars
films it's not unfair to draw a direct
comparisons with its long-standing
military shooter series after all from
my several hours of playing I suspect
that people who are going to enjoy this
the most are hardened battlefield fans
and that's fine because that series has
a legion of devotees who will be
deliriously happy on dices depiction of
half and Endor and Tatooine whether the
same rings true for casual Star Wars
fans who occasionally babbling games
however remains to be seen right now
you're looking at world first footage of
drop zone Bala Frank's new multiplayer
mode that pits two teams of a treble and
eight Empire players against each other
here on the rockbound surface of Sullust
an escape pod will crash onto a randomly
chosen part of the map players must dash
to the pods be the first to activate it
and then they have to defend it for 50
seconds if they're successful they own a
point for the team the opposing team
however must gain control of the pod by
deactivating it within that 50 second
limit if they do is thin their time to
defend once a point to scored the pod is
decommissioned and a new one drops onto
another part of the map after 10 minutes
of frantic chasing and breaching and
defending points are tallied and a
winning team is declared drop zone is an
artful spin on the king of the hill
formula with the same intensity in hot
zones but here players will routinely
abandon their camps and scramble to
different parts of the map this removes
any defender advantage places emphasis
on constant mobility and increases the
competitiveness of each map
but based on a short time I had with the
game it might be the case of drop zone
is too brutal to frenzied and too
demanding to enjoin anything other than
short bursts fingers will clamp down on
the dash button until they ate shootouts
a desperate short scuffles for survival
getting shot from behind is hardly ever
rectifiable and so last Sally's openings
and drop zones will typically have
several points where an enemy p counts
from i found little room for strategy
expression or flare its kill constantly
or be killed constantly again bala for
fans will have no problem with the
intensity the choke points the short
death loops other Star Wars fans may
find the ship rocity a little
off-putting other modes fair far better
EA is focused much of its battlefront
marketing on the Walker assault on Hoth
mode and it's easy to understand why
this is a sprawling epic 40 player
multi-objective team deathmatch often
punctuated by or inspiring moments
witnessing Luke Skywalker and Darth
evade a dash at each other in the midst
of this chaotic war zone was certainly a
personal pilot especially because these
heroes appear on the battlefield for
only a very limited time and I only
unlocked of players pick up various
items dotted across the battlefield
meanwhile the 80 80 s despite their
overexposure in Star Wars games are
still a sight to behold they also act as
an in-game progress bar for the Alliance
team as they cool towards the rebel base
with the ultimate objective to
obliterate it rebel players must capture
uplinks dotted across the map and if
successful this will summon a y-wing
that takes down the 80 80 s shields that
exposes these gargantuan walkers to
rebel gunfire which gives them a crucial
opening to win the match this setup
gives the Walker assault mode a clear
observable objective for both teams with
a sense of scale but also many moments
of consequence even the smallest battles
to gain control of an uplink feeds
directly into the wider grander
objective battlefront lacks a
single-player campaign and almost as an
apology dices answer for this is a small
collection of co-op missions which can
be played over online or on the couch
these are side attractions granted but
based on what I played they were a
pleasant surprise survival on Tatooine
is one such co-op mission it is
elementally afford mode where players
fight against five waves of increasingly
dangerous / tunes of stormtroopers with
a TS TS also making an appearance in the
later waves it makes her a nice break
from the intensity of multiplayer you
have more time to appreciate the game's
beautiful atmosphere it suddenly feels
like you're actually battling against
the Empire and of course being ordered
around by Admiral Ackbar it's always
wonderful but without a single player
campaign everything hinges on
multiplayer from the short time I had or
Battlefront I admire just how talented
dice is at building epic exciting and
constantly eventful online battles
whether that pleases not battlefield
fans is the crucial test I must admit
I'm a little skeptical Star Wars has
ballooned into an iconic multimedia
franchise with thousands of books and
comics action figures soundtracks and
games capitalizing on the popularity of
the films but at the heart of Star Wars
is long lasting appeal are the
characters and stories it contains its
tales of redemption of sacrifice and
family will likely survive as long as
the franchise itself star wars
battlefront may not have any stories of
its own to tell instead it gives you a
wonderful
polished brutal frantic multiplayer
games set inside elaborate film sets
that is absolutely not a disaster nor a
deviation from what the battlefront
series represented in the first place
but it begs the question is this really
the star wars game you're looking to
you